enseignants agents de la ratp personnels
hospitaliers toutes les professions
étaient représentées dans les cortèges
des différentes manifestations dans
l'hexagone a paris une 43e journée de
grève qui s'est déroulée sans heurts
entre les forces de l'ordre et les
protestataires
si certains manifestants sont confiants
quant à l'issue de la crise
il affirme surtout continuer la
mobilisation jusqu'à ce que le
gouvernement retire la réforme
on a un système qui est autonome et on
nous propose doubler nos cotisations à
74 1 28% pour une retraite qui va
baisser en fait de mille 400 à 1000
euros par ailleurs mais je suis un père
de famille mes enfants j'ai du mal à
expliquer puisque nature pour eux voilà
maintenant il faut que les
confédérations prennent leurs
responsabilités appel à la grève
générale parce que là on va pas s'en
sortir
6-6 macron veut s'accrocher à sa loi ben
il faut il faut y aller tous ensemble
vous appuyez sur le bouton faut bloquer
edf il tout bloquer tous voient pas
d'autre solution parce que là on tourne
en rond
il n'aurait pas dû toucher à cette
réforme de retard qui était d'entendre
qu'ils roulaient pas mal y avait pas
déficit c'est par un bref on aurait pu
améliorer les choses tranquillement on
aurait pris le temps qu'il faut donc là
c'est vraiment faire passer les mesures
renforcent un mépris total une arrogance
total une ironie total pour
l'intersyndicale
après six semaines de mobilisation la
détermination est toujours aussi grande
contre cette réforme n'a traversé une
période qui était compliqué c'était
entre noël et jour de l'an où beaucoup
de professions étaient en vacances de
gré ou de force j'allais dire et on voit
bien que en ce début d'année il ya
d'autres professions qui après les
assemblées générales ont décidé de
généraliser le mouvement d'amplifier le
mouvement j'avais sans doute noté que
l'intersyndicale qui s'est réunie hier a
déjà programmé d'autres journées
d'action la semaine prochaine voilà
c'est la réponse qu'on fait au
gouvernement s'il ne retire pas son
projet s'il n'accepte pas de discuter de
nos propositions pour améliorer le
système actuel quand est-ce que le
gouvernement va enfin écouter les
grévistes les salariés et l'opinion
publique qui le retrait provisoire de
l'âge pivot n'a donc pas suffi à calmer
le mécontentement des manifestants une
nouvelle journée d'action est d'ores et
déjà prévues le 24 janvier prochain
[Musique]